[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
uh
i did make a presentation that's gonna
maybe be up in a bit
i worked hard on it i made it in keynote
everyone else made it in google
present oh comic-con keynote there we go
that's my name and that's today
uh with a laser pointer and you can go
backwards oh and we can go
forwards but can we go backwards oh wow
we can go backwards and forwards that's
pretty cool
uh so we'll start at the beginning uh
this is me about five years ago i
see a bitcoin mug i wish i bought more
bitcoin back then
that's the comma ui up on the screen you
can see
we're detecting lane lines and you know
kind of making it work it's still the
engaged logo from star trek
this was the original comma system
uh it's been a long five years
uh had i known what this would have
ended up being
i probably never would have done it but
to be honest uh starting a company
is is absolute hell uh but
you know when you start out with things
you don't know this
right go into a full tilt right there we
go man
comma ai on the back of an acura ilx or
a license plate
right fuel on man it just means like
keep the keep the gas going bro
or uh you know um
uh so you know yeah we put this together
and you go for it it's like yo let's go
to the silicon valley vcs man you know i
was watching that show silicon valley
that's why it's called comma
hey if we're not having a good time
there's really no point doing this
um this is the original comma team
at an event self-racing cars
you know this was this was 2016 and a
lot of the companies back then
were way more honest and open um
i think that this self-driving space is
incredibly sad
uh i said this back in 2016
uh we are going to win self-driving cars
it still kind of holds true because you
know i don't like losing
and why do you keep doing it right
there's no point you know there's
nothing you can buy with money uh
there's no there's no amount of like i
live a nice life
but i like winning and i want to win so
that's why we're here and you know
i appreciate that you all came out
i remember uh before this tech crunch
disrupt
i was talking to my sister and i was
like saying like what i really want to
do is get up on stage pull my pants down
and take a [ __ ]
no really really because there's no
other way
like to to how do you compete when
everybody's just lying and so i'm like
all right we're going to go completely
over the top with it this is all you
need to solve self-driving cars
look it's in a neon grid it's a phone in
a neon green case
like it's kind of a joke but it's kind
of not
you know i think most of you have used
that phone to drive a car
i mean it's kind of a joke kind of not
well nishta wasn't it on the kind of a
joke so i'm like you know what
canceled cancelled no comma three uh
i'm sorry no com whoa whoa no comma one
the comma one was canceled um
alex roy wrote this article he got a
test drive in the car with the comma one
and
the canceled comma one would have
embarrassed the car industry
prediction there will be a comma two
well this wasn't all this was in october
one month later
we released openpilot open source really
all the ideas start to come together
it's like we're gonna be the android of
self-driving cars if tesla's the ios
we're going to be the android um so this
is openpilot 1.0
you can see it has a lot less directory
is it i didn't think i knew how to put
pictures and readmes back then
we figured it out it's pretty nice now
if you go to openpilot on github
and as for alex roy's prediction well
the open source software included the
neo
how many of you had neos all right we
got a few neo people out there how many
you had eons
all right and then how many you have
comma twos all right nice to see
um so it took a little bit for alex
roy's prediction to be
uh to come true but we did ship a comma
two
and it did embarrass the car industry
this is consumer reports if you guys
didn't see it
um
i mean open pilot is
is good you know how i know open pilot
is good
like i said i don't do this for money
i'm rich
i used to drive a mercedes s-class you
know like what other car are you gonna
buy right
but if you ask me today would i rather
have a mercedes s-class
or a hyundai sonata with a comma two
uh i think that that one's actually
better
right like that's how i know it's good
how much more does that car cost than
that car
even with the you know egregious price
of 1090. wow these things are priced way
too cheap we got to raise the prices
what does it mean to be good right so um
what's our slogan
meg driving chill uh so we like to say
the tesla slogan is look at this crazy
feature
i mean again maybe it appeals to a
different kind of audience but what does
it mean to be good
does it mean things like turning right
at an intersection well not really
because like
you just don't turn right that much in
your drives like it happens every once
in a while but
it's not that bad to do and i've been in
demos where the cars made autonomous
right turns it's stressful
it's stressful watching that wheel fly
in front of your face you're like do i
touch it do i not touch it is it gonna
do it i don't know i'm stressed out
right
our slogan is make driving chill so it's
not things like this
it's things like this so if you look
coming up to that exit
you can see that the lanes widen and
what almost every manufacturer lane keep
does
is it places you in the middle of those
two lanes
and you have an okay time right up until
you get to the fork
so what it should do is if you're going
left it should bug the left and if
you're going right it should
should hug the right but this stuff is
really hard
to program in in ways that are reliable
and repeatable and you saw this as some
of this in
in harold's presentation about like okay
let's say there was a dashed line there
right like it's just
there's there's so many variations and
what makes a system good isn't the crazy
things that it can do
but it's the things that it can do over
and over again repeatedly
and well that's what chill means to me
so uh yeah that's what it means to be
good
i remember i was uh
2008 it's like the knights of whoppers
i'd drive to burger king and go get
whoppers
that's my sister she wanted to come and
go to burger king and you know just
talking about things and i tell her you
know it's like impossible
uh to make a computer recognize whether
there's a chair in an image or not
like this is a task that a five-year-old
can do and in 2008
computers just couldn't do this and it
was because they were using a lot of
this sort of stuff
they'd run something like a harris
corner detector detect corners
uh compute some orb descriptors and then
come up with some like hacky definition
of what a chair was
based on some weird nearest neighbors
thing maybe
it just doesn't work right so
how do you actually detect chairs and
images this is a trivial problem i think
i think even a five-year-old can write
the code to do it now
um you know yeah import
uh import torch magic vision
uh torchmagic vision.predict and there
you go
and the way that this of course works is
they uh took lots and lots of images
and they labeled where the chairs were
and then they trained a neural net which
uses this algorithm called back
backpropagation
to improve the weights or the program
that's actually detecting the chair the
program is learned the program is not
hand coded
now you say no no no no but but waymo
learned this lesson right
they're not doing the stuff on the left
they're doing the stuff on the right
right they're they're they're getting
neural nets which put boxes around cars
they're
fully deep learned yeah but like
can these people think a little higher
in abstraction space
what's the meta lesson here right for
the task of prediction it's end to end
but the task of prediction is not the
task of driving
right it's unclear how you go from
prediction to driving
why why is this lesson still not learned
and why are these companies hiring cone
guys
well like really right you're gonna get
you're gonna gotta dive into the
taxonomy of cones
you have small cones you have large
cones what does it mean if a cone is
squashed
what about the big cones like this what
about the thing outside with the
you know is that a cone i don't know
gotta hire the cone guy for that right
um so yeah the lesson's really uh not
learned
uh one of the things we say at comma one
of the questions we ask
all the time is will this be in the
final system uh you know i find it
people are like i'm
by the way we're proud level two at
comma we're proud level two for two
reasons
one because the higher levels don't say
anything about capability they only talk
about liability
and we don't want liability obviously
but
you don't want things higher than level
two either do you want to tell the
machine what to do or do you want the
machine
to tell you what to do right what the
higher levels mean
is you're no longer in charge you're no
longer driving the car and like
some people might be okay with this like
i'm not i prefer that machines work for
me
and that i don't work for machines which
is kind of you know
that's long and philosophical but uh you
know we're level two forever
but there's no reason that a level two
driving agent
should not be a superhuman driver
there's no limit to it's like well it
can't be too good it's only level two
no way so we always ask the question
when we're building something and you
saw this this morning with the end to
end stuff it's like
will this be in the final system
uh so this is a real story uh from uh
a secret internal source at that company
um they had these cars and they were
driving this little loop around
pittsburgh and
they really got the loop working well in
the winter it could drive the loop most
of the time without a disengagement
um but in the winter well
the bike racks looked like this right
car drove by
fine on the street and it was all good
but then spring
came and the system stopped working the
system stopped finishing the same loop
that it could do in winter
and they checked all their hd maps and
they were all good it was a localization
issue
the bike rack didn't look like this the
bike rack looked like this
now if you're trying to build a system
that individually picks out each bike
then runs a complicated prediction model
on what that bike is going to do
how big is your computer this of course
isn't how humans do it at all
right humans just look at those things
they're like oh it's a bunch of bikes in
iraq
uh so well what did uber end up doing
they put that area in the map as an area
with a bike rack and they said don't
detect any bicycles in that area
we all know all right oh we won't we
won't
talk anymore about that but uh you know
will this be in the final system is a
real question and a
hand coded this is a bike rack don't
detect any bikes in this area would
never be in any sane
uh final you know superhuman driving
system
another question we ask is is this how a
human does it right
um so when we think about like we're
trying to like do some tasks we think
hey you know let's let's
think about how a human does it because
humans are the only
implementation of driving today people
talk about how humans are bad drivers
humans are so much better than every
self-driving car
out there available or not available
today do you know how i know that
because the second
that flips everything's going to be
self-driving
but we're nowhere near there yet right
so like people are like oh humans crash
cars
humans almost never crash cars i saw a
good graph i probably should have put in
here was a pie chart of like
during your commute how many times you
crash and it was like
a thousand times no crash maybe one time
crash maybe
maybe a million times no crash one time
crash
um humans crashed cars very rarely
so there's only one safe policy for
driving
um and it's not just ask how a human
does it because a human probably does it
in a good way
everybody in self-driving understands
that you want to build
systems that are capable of predicting
what the cars around you will do
but you do understand that humans are
writing that exact same algorithm
humans are trying to predict what all
the other cars will do and they're
assuming
implicitly that humans are driving them
so driving with an
inhuman policy is dangerous
right you can say oh yeah but
technically you rear-ended me
you have the liability yeah but if you
slammed on your brakes in the middle of
a highway like you can make that
argument but you still crashed
there's only one safe policy for driving
and that's the human policy
assuming you want to inter-operate on
roads with other humans
now you're going to get some wacko
utopian people who are like we're going
to replace all the humans with bunk
people and
um you know we'll put the bug people in
the cars and the bug people drive
according to these very very rigid rules
but you know this is
well i don't know i like driving
take it away right there's only one safe
policy for driving that's the human
policy
this is our mission solve self-driving
cars while delivering shippable
intermediaries
a cool test that i like to use about
whether somebody is saying something
is ask the question of what else they
might be saying
right like does the opposite of this
make any sense um you know if some
politician gets on the stage and says
we care about the children could you
ever imagine a politician
getting on a stage and saying what you
know the children aren't that important
to us
no of course not um so what's in this
mission
is very clear about what we have to do
but it's also clear about what we're not
trying to do
we're not trying to deliver a return to
our investors
sorry investors um we're not trying to
uh aggrandize ourselves with
self-importance by throwing big events
with lots and lots of poi
um uh
no we are we're here to have a good time
too but fundamentally
this is the goal of our company right
and it makes it very easy for everybody
to be aligned the amount of political
how are we winning if you believe we're
winning
how are we winning what are these other
companies doing wrong and they
understand some technical
stuff wrong but i think they also
understand some philosophical stuff
wrong
this is our company mission solve
self-driving cars
while delivering shippable
intermediaries
uh and that brings me to the next slide
business
so comma is a business that is our goal
and that is the mission of the business
but comma is a business we do have to
operate in the business world
uh this is a quote from my uh
self-driving uh
my 100x investment blog post it's so sad
it's really it's really so sad how
[Music]
yeah um and it's because business
selects for psychopathy
uh maybe you guys saw the nicola founder
was was indicted
um yeah you know he he he uh told
and he told the world that his truck
fully worked but actually what he did
was he tilted the camera a little towed
the truck to the top of a hill and had
it rolled down and didn't put a motor in
it
right even boomers understand that's a
scam right
um
so you know it's always nice to see that
but it's these these scams that are much
more intricate that you don't exactly
you know it's not exactly clear to point
to the scam but when you just look at a
company that's raised
10 billion dollars and has no revenue
and now is like we're gonna do an ipo
like it went from companies aren't
profitable to companies don't have
revenue to companies don't have
users right so
i promise this is the downer part of the
talk
the the stuff that i really like talking
about is coming up
um so the fundamentals of us as a
business uh we've raised 8.1 million
dollars
uh we've made 9 million in revenue
the next milestone here is to have over
8.1 million dollars in assets
and the next milestone after that is to
have over 8.1 million dollars in cash
because then undoubtedly we've created
something right and i like that i like
that from a business perspective like
figure out how to you know make money
um we sold five thousand comma twos
uh this is now the majority funding
source of the company
and it's great because we're aligned
with you comma wants the same things you
do
we want openpilot to be better you want
openpilot to be better we want to build
better products you want us to build
better products this is the beauty of
capitalism when it works
right it's like you're 3 500 weekly
active users
this is a wild statistic in the context
of how many we've sold
over 50 percent of every piece of
hardware we've sold
is still being used every week the only
thing that i know that competes with
that
is like appliances and mobile phones
this beats laptops this beats game
consoles and this crushes virtual
reality headsets
the average use for a virtual reality
had the average number of times people
use a virtual reality headset is one
right fifty percent still in use over
over a three year uh we sold about two
thousand eons
um so it's yeah it's it's over fifty
percent uh still in use
these are our shopify numbers uh i
challenge
other businesses out there to start
doing this uh post
screenshot from shopify you can see our
sales going up
you can see our average order value is
going up and you can see our total
orders are going up
um average order value is a important
one that i like because these things are
going to get more expensive as they get
better
um a lot of companies if you're really
talking about the kind of smash and grab
approach or like the exit scam you see
in a lot of companies what they'll do
with their hardware pricing
is they'll price it very high at the
beginning capture the early adopters
money who'll pay whatever they want and
then lower the price over time i'm not
doing that
we price it and then we raise the price
and we've done that with every release
um you know the comma 2 went up a little
bit in price uh so yeah the
the order value goes up over time but we
also think the value that openpilot
delivers
has gone up over time would you guys
agree yeah
[Applause]
so weekly devices by type uh so you
can see our weekly active users about uh
the 3500 we talked about
uh one of the things that i like here is
this yellow line here is the comma two
so most of our users are on comma twos
uh which
to me signifies that we've actually
delivered uh uh
enough of a better experience uh for
people to upgrade
um we did we did uh sadly deprecate the
original eon but we offered free trades
to everybody
just pay shipping to eon golds if you
wanted to stick on the old system
we do want to support this stuff for as
long as we feasibly can
but remember you know i'm not a no child
left behind guy i'm a gifted program guy
uh so you know we do want to push the
high end and we especially want to push
the experience
for uh you know all the
the majority right the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few it's a
vulcan quote
we are comfortably in control of our own
destiny
um this is nice this took some time
we're not ipo'ing we're definitely not
specking we're not selling out to
bankers
uh i'm i'm the majority shareholder i'm
the sole board member
and i am 100 committed to the company
mission i've never sold a share
uh my salary 78 thousand dollars a year
uh i don't care
it doesn't it doesn't really matter
right and this is an important thing to
realize right like
i think about how good my life is i live
in a beautiful apartment in downtown san
diego and my life is good
because i have things like hvac you're
the king of france you couldn't get hvac
you could order all your minions build
me an hvac system and they'd be like
want to invade poland what um
so we're comfortably in control of our
own destiny and we are committed to
making
better and better technology every year
why don't we work with car companies we
get this question a lot and sometime
i'll give some flip and answer about how
they're hard to work with
but there was always just something that
like never
sat right and i think i can put some
good business terms on it now since this
is the business section
uh so this is the gross margin in
automotive it's 18 percent
automotive is mostly a you're going to
like grind out for these little margins
you know the dealers take their cut
it's a very like protected industry um
you know that's like like look at tesla
trying to get their direct to consumer
model working like the dealerships are
protecting their little cut
and you you don't want to be in a place
where everybody's fighting over a small
piece of the pie
you want to be in a place where a large
pie benefits everybody
you want to be in a space where the
gross margin is high
because it lets you it gives you room to
experiment and like have fun and like
build cool things
um so the gross margin automotive is 18
the gross margin in consumer electronics
58
we're an aspiring consumer electronics
company
no like this isn't comma's transitory
business model look we're not going to
be selling dev kits forever
but well let's talk about our total
addressable market
more business trips you guys um we
support over 130 cars
that's over 50 percent of all new cars
sold in the us
in numbers that's about 8 million
compatible cars per year there's about
25 million potential existing users this
is in the us alone
uh that's 0.02 market penetration to
date
we have a huge addressable market right
is it always going to be a dev kit that
you
self-install that you have to know what
a panda is no
it's going to be a consumer electronics
product it's going to be like a
well let's just say if we build this
i can easily see a 1 million devices per
year market that's like five percent
market penetration that's nothing
at a minimum of a thousand dollars each
you guys know what a thousand times a
million is right
[Applause]
um this is i'm bringing back an old
comma slogan
we're going to be so rich
we also briefly made comma gym wear like
a tank top it said we're going to be so
ripped
um you know this was a good pitch to the
investors but this is that's
kind of true comma is defining the next
device class of consumer electronics
right the smartphone the tablet
the portable media player uh
the laptop right the
advanced driver assistance system i
don't know if there's a better name for
it but
you know we want to be the android i
don't want to be the only company
building this hardware open pilot's open
source
i think in the next five years we're
going to see a ton of these things start
to pop
up because the total addressable market
is huge the potential for profit is huge
and like i said her company mission is
to solve self-driving cars the more
people we got thinking about this stuff
the more people who wanna
it's not working with us right it's not
like it's not a partnership it's not a
sketchy backroom deal it's like
here's who we are come play in this
beautiful ecosystem we're paving the way
for you
right maybe one of you out there maybe
one of you out there is making
you know action cameras or some some
again there's another consumer
electronics uh device class
right build a open pilot compatible
device
let's live in a world where there's 10
of these to choose from
right and i've seen i've seen a few cool
things you know i'll give a shout out to
blue box
they launched a kickstarter i think
their device is a little too cheap and a
little underpowered
but it's the right idea um
i know i'd love to see a world where you
can just like android phones you can
pick from a whole lot of these to choose
from
all right
that's the business section now the
stuff that i like talking about i told
you to get more upbeat
that's a picture from a coma too
you know what question i get asked all
the time
george how are you going to solve
self-driving cars with one
camera um
well this is the comma two camera and
it's like pretty good you can pretty
much see what to do on that road
but what if there's a car next to you
and it's a little hard to make out
what's going on in the distance
so no the comma two now we can say it
the comma 2 is not
good enough to build a level 5
self-driving car out of
i hope you all knew this right
it's a driver assistance system but
you know we do want to get better like i
said
we're not stopping oh they're going to
stop come ai only does highway
do it all there's no distinction
but we are going to need
more cameras
who's ready to count
one
two
three
[Music]
uh
[Music]
man i always wanted to do one of these
you know
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right uh so this is the comma three
uh you know you guys can see a few
changes
it's nice and slim the display is
stunning
i don't want to talk about how much i'm
paying for those displays
it's more than the whole like
you can see navigation on the right
uh you know you see the basics the the
open pilot interface on the left
uh you can see down here we have this is
185 degree lens
uh infrared these are the same two
infrared leds
uh that are on the comma two so you get
that same great nighttime driver
monitoring
this is what the device looks like from
the back
uh yes we finally made injection molded
cases
they look nice um you'll see that we
have two eyes
uh but not for binocular not for stereo
vision stereo vision at long distances
is relatively useless
although this does exceed the human
baseline so if any of you we're wrong
we got the stereo we got the hardware
for stereo uh in here
again like i said it's useless but what
it is useful for is you can see the two
cameras on the back
have different uh lenses so that's 185
degree lens on the right
and that's like a 45 degree lens on the
left so you can see
objects that are really far away um
speaking of the cameras they're really
good
uh 1080p oh but george the eon has a 16
megapixel sensor
and it does so why is this only 1080p
the eons lens can resolve about 0.5
megapixels
it's not about how many megapixels you
shoved into your sensor
it's about how many you can reasonably
use and resolve
um the sensor has you know what's the
benefits of less pixels looking i could
put
i'm paying a lot for these sensors i
could put a 16 megapixel sensor in there
but you're not going to get better
pictures
your picture quality has a lot to do
with how good your lens is
and how good your uh how big your pixels
are
right bigger pixel more light uh more
light
equals less noise uh so yeah these are
uh
there you can also see that the lenses
are fixed focus
uh so one of the big problems with the
the comma two data is it's kind of
blurry
uh especially when you're like braking
hard or when you're
the way that it works is the lens is on
this tiny spring and then you have like
uh like a piezo as a
like actuator uh to to to press on the
lens uh here we don't have any of these
we focus these at the factory at
infinity
um the depth of field is plenty to
capture everything you need
whew
all right um
so about 1080p uh 120 db of high dynamic
range
uh so that's up from 85 in the comma two
uh two 185 degree lenses for full 360
degree coverage yes we can see all the
way around the car
narrow cam for far away the human eye
actually doesn't have sensors equally
distributed throughout the eye you have
a center of the eye called the fovea
which is a very dense
uh area digital sensors aren't like this
digital sensors are in grids but you can
mimic this by using two cameras and
that's why the device has two cameras on
the back
it has a fovea and it has a
the fovea i'm sure there's a warrior and
some
optometrists would know uh it's a
ar-0231 automotive sensor there is a
zero two three three you cannot buy it
this is the best sensor you can buy
it's two generations ahead of teslas um
[Applause]
let's take a look at some pictures
uh this is me and alex chillin on the
five
um look at the upper left
you can really see look at look at that
road texture that we're now capturing
uh full 360 you can see that down here
you can see that
front pillar we didn't consider this
when we did the balloons
don't pop the balloons
uh yeah you can see uh you know the
driver monitoring
uh captures a whole lot more so there's
no more fiddling with your device
like aim it in the right sort of way
uh to make sure it sees your face
it always sees your face it even sees
whether your hands are on the wheel
uh oh by the way it also sees next to
your car
right so if there's like a sammy dexter
we see it now we see everything
this is its performance at night
yeah that's what those big pixels get
you look at how in the narrow picture
you can't even see that car right there
um the the gamma curve on this uh
i don't know about the gamma curve on
this screen it seems pretty harsh
but you can easily make out that car on
a computer screen
so that means the net can as well uh
driver monitoring at night with that
infrared
uh yeah nighttime pictures
it's not a cell phone
we used zero cell phone part well i mean
it depends what you mean
you use a snapdragon 845
qualcomm's chips are half the price and
more performance than nvidia's
a lot of people don't use qualcomm
because uh the software is nowhere near
as like there's no easy sdk to use
qualcomm
so like the snapdragon 845 uses a
completely different
camera the hardware is completely
changed from the 820.
yeah we reverse engineered that one too
it's in camera two and open pilot
um so it's great that we can use the
qualcomm chips
and we plan to stick with qualcomm
really all the way to the end uh
wi-fi and global lte connectivity so it
has the same connectivity as a cell
phone
uh of course that works with comma prime
it's got wi-fi it has bluetooth too
we don't really test it so you know well
not good as bluetooth but uh no i'm sure
the bluetooth works
we did test we did test the antennas we
got this device fcc approved
the device has an fcc id um
a 2160 by 1080 oled display
uh no more no more issues with
sunglasses and did you polarize it
diagonally no it's not polarized it's an
oled
i hear it actually might still be
polarized but it works great with
sunglasses
um now the display is really stunning
you know you guys know the beauty of
oled the blacks are actually black
there's no bleed there's no local
dimming there's nothing like that it's
actually uh
um we went above and beyond i should
have included the video we calibrated
each oled
display we had all this code to
calibrate the camera for colors
and it was pretty easy to also just do
the display so every display that goes
through our factory
we put a uh put a little camera on top
of it
and calibrate it to the uh to have the
exact same color response as every other
comma 3.
i believe even apple doesn't do that um
apple you can and apple's very good
about this apple has some of the best
displays in the industry
we actually take the time to calibrate
it that's the cool thing about having 58
gross margins
we can do things like this that are just
kind of you know above and beyond
another thing that's above and beyond uh
yeah we put a real gaming ssd in there
like
like why not it's almost the same price
per gigabyte as sd cards
but why would you use a crappy little uh
oh it writes
did you buy a class 7 or a class 9. no
we bought a samsung 980 nvme
ssd you guys will see we have some
interior pictures coming up
high precision gps same one as a comma
2.
and obdc port same as the comma two the
harnesses are compatible
uh so it's the exact same harness if you
do buy a comma three you do not need to
buy another harness
uh we include it has a right angle cable
the cable is a bit nicer
uh but that's included in the box so you
don't need to buy harness if you're
upgrading from a comma two
uh it also has a usb 3.1 gen 2 port
uh so finally we have real expansion
capabilities on this device
uh you're actually going to be hearing
we already have one expansion
device being also maybe announced later
but uh this usb port is capable of
streaming out the entire sensory on the
device
so the five gigabits of bandwidth would
allow us to stream all the cameras in
full resolution if say we wanted to
attach an external i don't know gtx 3090
to it
uh to run some really huge models um
also just because it only cost a dollar
uh that's also a display port so you can
connect it to a big screen
uh some of you guys want the comma
screen you can do it uh
you're going to have to get the west and
a little software but the hardware works
so yeah this is the front of motherboard
you can see this is the 845 som uh
the we have a heatsink which sits on top
of that you know one of the problems
with cell phones the comma 2 runs hot
uh the comma 2 the uh
it's very hard so the processor on the
comma 2 faces the screen
in a cell phone it's really hard to deal
with heat because the only place really
to dump that heat
would be in the user's hand so they try
to dump it out the screen but it doesn't
work that well
um you know it's glass it's not metal it
would make a glass heat sink
uh so we can put the heatsink right on
top of
well right on top of the memory which is
right on top of the processor
um but in the stress test the comma twos
get up to 90 degrees
uh celsius in the stress test for the
comma three which is when we run it at
full tilt
they range between like 60 and 65. so
they they run
they run 25 to 30 degrees celsius
colder at full power than the comet ii
and it's because we can shove the
heatsink right on there uh
so uh well we'll get to this in a minute
there's still a little android in the in
the
in the thing uh in the device but we
keep it in that metal box there
uh we keep all the android in there
don't worry there's a there's a cover on
it it holds the android in
it's the only way to get an lte modem we
stuck a great lte modem that's that's
the global edition
uh we've done some some speed tests
you're getting uh
i think i've seen it up to like 80
megabytes a second um
80 megabits a second it's lte and it's
good
uh part of the reason it's good also is
um you know a cell phone has these like
crappy little antennas that have to go
through your hand
we have two big antennas on either side
with ground planes behind
this and you know user's not touching it
so the lte reception is great
uh that's the front of the motherboard
uh this is the usb
3.1 port this is the obdc port there's a
daughter board which sticks on top of
here that i don't have a picture of
it has super capacitors on it uh so you
have about five seconds of power
after you pull the thing uh this lets us
write the logs to disk in a safe way
it also gives us time to alarm if the
device does immediately lose power
so it's the best of both worlds it's not
a battery it's a capacitor
uh and you still get some power uh after
if the
if say your car uh catastrophically
loses 12 volts
uh you still have some uh
you don't immediately kill the device so
yeah that sits right on top of there
there's a speaker also i should have
gotten pictures of it uh two digital
microphones
uh you know
everything i like they're like little
people two eyes
two ears a mouth a brain
an lte rate well
[Laughter]
this is the back uh there's that uh nvme
uh that's the display connector
underneath there
is the uh ir led driver
this is a panda uh so you guys know what
the panda in the comma
two was called right does anyone know
the code name
the uno uh this one's a dose
just a dose uh got a sim card right here
rtc battery audio codecs
sourcing for these things you know you
guys know about the pandemic sourcing
and like
like we got it uh
yeah these were these were one of the
parts that was tricky to get
um open pilot at launch uh if you guys
have been watching the code base this is
tc
it's already better than the comma 2
with 087
and this is for two reasons uh it's not
due to training we've barely trained on
any comma 3s but
the fixed focus of the camera means that
it never goes blurry
and the processor is eight cores instead
of four cores so every open pilot
process practically has its own core
uh so your timings are much more
consistent your focus is a lot better so
open pilot is already a better
experience out of the box
agnos a great new operating system no
more neo s it's ubuntu 2004 based
apt-get just works i did i did one of
these devices like how did that work
don't we have the system partition
mounted read only
uh and like my the reply on slack is
like no no we added a hook
it mounts it read write and then it lets
you apt get something and then it mounts
it read only again i'm like that's so
nice
this is like a nice development
environment this is a ubuntu 2004
computer
as far as i know we're the first company
to ship a qualcomm device with linux
and navigation alpha is ready that's not
a mock
this is the whole reason we built comma
prime you think i wanted to deal with um
carrier i can't name uh and write a
writer like sign a contract to like
resell some
no but we got to ship navigation to you
guys i mean you need navigation if you
want to solve level 5 self-driving or
superhuman self-driving or anything no
liability
and you know what i'll be honest about
how good the navigation is right so if
you kind of rank these like
carplay android auto how many of you use
that for navigation
and mostly it's pretty nice right um
then maybe and sometimes you'll rent a
car and you'll use phone and cupholder
navigation um
and then sometime you use the uh
actually i don't know you'll never use
the built-in oem navigation you'll
always use the phone and cupholder right
so uh the comma three nav is better than
phone and cupholder
um so and then once we do ship uh
navigate on open pilot i think then
maybe
uh we can jump that but there's no way
to jump that right now it is i'm not
going to lie to you and tell you it's
better than
than carplay but it's a very usable
experience
uh more so than your phone and a couple
there you'll be hearing more about this
in the next presentation
you want to stand up everyone who was in
epot
i think seven of the epot people made it
out here
um these people have had the device for
four months
they've been testing it they've given us
feedback we went through two revisions i
now release
you from your nda so feel free to talk
about your honest experience with the
device
uh is it perfect no but a lot of the
bugs are software
uh and it's now now it's good
four months ago it was kind of meh six
months ago
maybe fifty percent of the time it would
work now we don't even have combat twos
in the car anymore
uh you guys saw maybe some of you saw on
the stream our leaked user admin screen
where all the cars had comma threes uh
so this device has been tested in the
field for months we've done
way more testing on this than we did on
the comma two
um we also ported over all our
factory test uh infrastructure uh from
the comma two to the comma three
so these devices all for example have a
24 hour stress test we test every sensor
we test the microphones we test the
speakers we test everything in this
device
uh you know our goal is really as we go
forward to drive reliability of these
things up
to the point that you know someday
hypothetically if you ever have a comma
seven
the thing's never going to break but the
comma three should be a good bit better
than the comma two
on that front uh so yeah
thank you epot
now who knows what this slide is
what do you think's on it
69 420 yeah uh this is the price slide
three thousand dollars
now they started 21.99
[Music]
double a comma two uh starting at 21.99
now there are two variants of it
so before you you know go on your phone
and place your order right now
uh you may want to wait to hear what the
other variant is
so yeah these devices are not uh it's
not a pre-order
uh this is pictures from our factory
this week uh
they're already uh in production and the
first ship date is thursday
now if you want to be in on that first
ship date well you want to buy the cross
country edition
uh the cross country edition has one
terabyte of storage it's the high
trim so if you guys like that like king
ranch f-150 it's like this is the
cross-country edition uh it comes with
this sick looking boot badge
um and it ships first uh so all orders
are first in first out but there's a
bit of a priority element to that we
fulfill all one terabyte orders and then
we start fulfilling the 250 gig
which is the 21.99 base model this one's
27.99
uh so yeah those are the two models the
site should be up right now
uh first in first out and this is the uh
this is the comma three
thank you everyone uh you know really
i'm super impressed with the team that
built this
uh we have really
you know the the the people on the comma
team now i mean you saw some of them
this morning
it's uh it gets harder and harder to
beat us every day
uh i'm starting to think we're going to
win
i'm starting to think i wasn't an fsd
beta
i'm starting to think we're going to
beat them sorry i think we're going to
beat everybody
ah yeah
there's a bunch of comma 3s in the back
uh for you guys to actually go and check
out and touch
actually i think i might have one
right here
it comes in this beautiful stealth black
box
that it will ship in so when it shows up
on your uh you know doorstep it doesn't
say 21.99 on it
um
see the cross-country badge is included
on the leaflet as well uh this is the
most complicated text we've ever shipped
shows you how to mount it
ah and then whoops
right under here you'll see an actual
comma 3 in the box
yeah in here
you'll find the accessories bag
just get this open i'm sure someone will
do a much more beautiful unboxing
of this device than i can and you'll see
the accessories bag here
which is what includes the harness if
you order one or if you don't order a
harness
it's just the mounts a bunch of stickers
uh adhesive and this right angle cable
this bag doubles as a carrying case for
the device
so if you do want to take it off your
windshield you can put it in this
beautiful microfiber
cloth
so that's it that's the comment three
now i think it's time for questions
all right guys i picked the wrong day to
wear shoes covered in spikes
it's not my birthday
all right
it begins um all right
we got a question up top first great
looks terrific george uh congratulations
to the whole comma team
um my question is are the harnesses the
same for the comma two as they are for
the comma three
absolutely if you have a comma two uh we
even made a special uh
video of chris made a special video uh
for upgrading from the two to the three
it's super easy it's the exact same
harness so all you need to buy is the
device
i will say that the site is now live
sweet
and we will be shipping first in first
out so that's your chance to get first
in line
um we got a question up there
go for it yeah hey so
um
that sounds so boring what am i going to
get up here and show you sexy pictures
of
auto insurance
i can't believe that's the first time
we've heard that
listen listen that's great and they can
do that they're welcome to they're
welcome to play in our ecosystem we
we're not going to tell them not to
but but after we solve self-driving cars
let's solve home robotics and agi i
don't know
insurance sounds boring
you know the comet 3 is a it's a little
head kind of you know
i'll take it out it can be it can be
touched um
all right i got a question back here
george you guys see the similarities
two eyes two ears a mouth
a usb por what power goes in right
all right i got a question back here
hello what are the biggest challenges
with building a world-class team
and how do you and kama overcome these
challenges
uh basically we do very little outreach
we mostly reach in and you can ask
yourself this question
do you want to scam for the rest of your
life or do you want to come here and
actually build something
that's it and people show up and they
want to build something they got skills
they're motivated welcome to comma
um is there anything different about the
cross-country edition other than the
storage and the
uh and the badge like do you upgrade my
car's warranty here
um i i would uh cross country is also
included
right here the cross country edition has
enough storage for an entire drive
across the country
that's why it's named the cross country
edition
and it it ships first and uh yeah
cross-country edition
[Laughter]
they're both great they're they're both
a great choice
hello i already ordered my comma three
thank you
great persuaded um
this is who funds our company uh so i'll
preface this with
i also think he's completely
insufferable but why so much shade for
elon
what what shade did i throw at elon look
i know i actually have a lot of respect
for you
i seriously do um elon is a man who
has a positive vision for the future and
that's what we need more of today uh
elon can talk about the future in such a
way that it's a future that i want to
live in
uh so you know we're just playing you
gotta have a word of the adversary right
if he's sherlock holmes on moriarty
all right we gotta we got a question
upstairs but mori already respects you
know mr holmes
hi jonathan hey george
nice nice product uh what's the kind of
benefit of having more storage
like practically speaking oh just stores
more stuff
like porn
the driving performance is the same on
both devices you can choose which one
you want to buy
yeah um another question uh is there a
new trading
program for existing users of some sorts
not yet so we
made i'm gonna say never say never
but probably not yeah so you know where
we're
it's not like we have a warehouse full
of thousands of these uh we are
building them as we speak so you know
maybe someday if we have excess
uh capacity but they're you know they're
kind of hard to make and like we make
them we test them we reject all the ones
that fail even one test
uh so you know they're going to be
probably
fairly limited supply for a bit um maybe
after that changes we'll see oh with
respect to the comma two
uh so we still have i think it's 791
comma twos in stock
uh we're not going to stop selling them
um the comma two from today
is going to be supported for one more
year uh so there's going to be one more
year of open pilot updates
it's not going to get features like
navigation navigation is hard to make
work on the comma 2 the processor just
doesn't have that much more power
but things like enter and longitudinal
will likely come to the comma two as
well
uh no promises but we're not gonna
artificially you know things that are
easy for us to make work on the comma
two we'll also work on the comma two
and there will be at least one more year
of core open pilot software support
thanks i got a question all the way in
the back in the center what's up george
awesome products thank you is the c3
so is the storage replaceable and
upgradable by the user
wow
yeah we gotta go to the picture oh these
take
yeah i will warn you
that actually these drives the reason we
use the samsung drives isn't just
because i'm a nice guy
uh it's because um most of them are
egregiously bad at low power modes
uh so i mean you can change it
but when your device you know kills your
car battery
uh you can check it all you can check it
all it's not as easy it's not like you
know you have a desktop where power is
effectively unlimited
um so yeah you'd want to make sure that
whatever drive you put in does work with
uh low power modes but you know that's a
that's a pcie slot
uh if you put anything in there we
tested with a google corel as well
if hypothetically we want to put an
accelerator in there
great uh this is a question about the
driver facing camera in the sensor
fusion stack
so it seems like the car frame is going
to be
possibly a factor uh that that's
invariant
or not invariant across card designs how
do you intend to
get around that one fusing the cameras
um so probably the same way we do
everything which is big data uh
as long as we i'm so sorry
as long as we have enough data from
enough users the models will become
invariant to this
um maybe we'll re-hash back to one of
the things how does a human do it
what it's kind of it's not that big of a
deal
um let me just say so i also already
ordered my cross country edition
right here do you see there being
plans for some kind of like century mode
um of way of like with that expanded
storage
uh next talk we'll kind of get into some
of this stuff
so remember that every resource comma
puts on something that's not
self-driving is a resource that's taken
away from self-driving
uh so you know it's not high on our
priority lists
but this stuff does still have to be
usable we have some cool announcements
in the next talk
hey george congratulations and uh
just wanted to ask you to touch on the
boot time or the boot time
uh well you know it's not you guys know
i'm just a cheerleader
right like i'm just the guy who comes up
and presents these
uh so you know it's really
congratulations to the team
uh the boot time is
it's been a while since i've used a
comma two but i think it's better it's
not
too much better and there's a lot more
that we can do here that we couldn't do
on the comma two
uh so for example the comma two is a
leica with a locked
and you can flash whatever kernel you
want but the bootloader is signed
there's no signing enabled on the comma
three uh so we can go all the way up the
stack and our goal is to get boot times
down to five seconds
but that's not hardware that's software
uh so you know
it'll get better over time uh i would
say now it is at least as good as the
comma two
all right i'm coming for you we are one
of our things at comma is always
no regressions no regressions no
regressions
yeah so i was wondering about the uh if
you look in into the
commercial use case for this because it
seems like it it would be very
interesting for fleets
and also given that um it seems like
people are asking
the uh the self-driving ceos about
uh uh crypto i'd be much more interested
to hear your thoughts
than uh someone else's uh
all right so what was your first
question
uh so it's limit two per customer right
now uh due to limited supplies but that
will go away
i think we'll do the same sort of bulk
discounts look i'm not working with them
but can they buy them and use them
absolutely
i'm not going to say no right like you
know what one of the things that i
really like
um you know one of the things that i
during like the playstation hacking i
would say stuff like
when i buy this playstation it's mine to
do whatever i want with and i feel the
exact same way about common products
right like if some fleet wants to buy
them and use them we're not going to
tell you no
nobody asks you what you're going to use
it for you might get banned from our
servers if you you know make unsafe
changes but that's
our servers right your device is yours
to do anything you want with and i
really
believe in that um so uh yeah can fleets
buy them and use them absolutely
and what's my take on crypto oh well
pump pump pump pump
tether to the floor die to two dollars
cheap
so on the business side you kind of
covered the u.s
market um and the potential there but i
was kind of curious if you could share
some
on the european market or other markets
in the world
i'll ship it to any country that doesn't
ban me or charge insane import taxes
so you are in those markets and you see
growth
oh if someone from another country
orders and pays the shipping charge and
pays the import charge again i'm not
going to say no
i'm not a no kind of guy
we don't track any of that okay right um
i guess i get to be the third to say
i've
ordered mine so cool
all right things are looking good for
how many we ordered
[Applause]
so it runs linux so probably it could be
used as a hotspot
with great antennas it sounds like um
that'd be nice in the car to have like a
good reception maybe or something
oh yeah i mean the the comma two can be
used as a hotspot too we have the same
feature
uh you can toggle tethering it works uh
you can also so our sim is is is
not that fast uh the comma prime sim is
uh half megabyte
uh the upload is faster though but it's
supposed to be half megabyte symmetric
but it's actually like 1.3 if anyone
benchmarked it
but uh that's a nice lte modem if you
stick a real sim in there and turn it on
yeah it works great
sounds awesome um and are you also aware
that you probably
built a pretty great uh baseline you
hackling vr a lot but that's a pretty
great baseline for kind of another case
and it'd be a nice vr
device as well um yeah
vr has a bunch of challenges
i can talk about this stuff at length
some other time
uh it's unclear what the the beauty of
the comma 3 is when you buy it uh
when it gets to you you're going to be
able to use it to improve your life
tomorrow
right no waiting for anything i mean you
guys use open pilot
if you like open pilot with the comma
two you're gonna like it even more with
the comma three
so you said beautiful product and great
presentation
uh he said something to the effect of uh
level two the machine you tell the
machine what to do and higher levels
the machine tells you what to do can you
say more
and maybe give us a glimpse into your
road map
well when you get in away mo and when
you touch the steering wheel it pulls
over and locks you out
who owns that machine i like owning the
machine and open pilot when you take the
wheel you turn it it's your wheel you
paid for it
does that answer the question i'm not
sure what else there is what is our road
map get to superhuman as fast as we can
win self-driving cars right i don't know
look if i was betting i'd still probably
bet on tesla but we'll be close
all right question on the navigation how
what's um so do you expect me to reach
for the screen and just type it in there
or
is it gonna be through that god what am
i trying to build an oem navigation
experience
yes please scroll through each letter no
go on your phone and type in the
destination and it goes over prime and
it's sent to your device it's real nice
um we do have uh shortcuts that you can
program in from your phone
you'll see more about this in the next
presentation but you think i'd design
something terrible like that
i'm telling you i use it i want to use
these things i drive around that hyundai
sonata with openpilot
i use the nav i'm not using it if i'm
piping in oh no i hit the d oh
my question is does nav integrate with
like auto lane change or suggested lane
soon soon uh so we need to gather the
data first uh so remember that the way
comma works is we gather the data from
from all our users and we use the data
to train the models
so once there's a whole bunch of comma
threes out there all the comma threes
will get better
and we'll we will put it this way
navigate on open pilot is a simpler
feature to build than end to end
longitudinal
we know how to build it i'll tell you
guys
you see that nav screen we you know we
wrapped our brain for a while about like
what's the api right we have the desire
stack you'll hear more about that desire
is cool for things like lane changes
which aren't covered in naf
but like for all the rest of it well we
just asked the question how do humans do
it
well humans watch waze right or watch a
nav system so we're just gonna take the
picture from the nav system and shove it
in a cob net and put it into the model
and i think it's totally gonna work
why would it not right if a human can
learn from that information so can the
machine
so navigate on open pilot is uh
will look i don't like being a lot and
making predictions i can't keep
but uh i'm sorry i'm ripping on eli you
know i got a lot of respect for the guy
i don't even rip one who's the comma
i don't even know right um
oh there's two oh the co-ceos yes that's
a great sign guys
um he's ceo no he's ceo
um oh she all right um
that diversity that's good uh
uh yeah i would say that there's an 80
likelihood
that we ship navigate and open pilot
within the next year
okay so you talk about how you want
comma to kind of become
like an ecosystem like android is sure
you know what products do you think
are you excited to see you know um for
you know the ecosystem as of now yeah so
we're focused on the high end and this
is the decision that we had to make as a
company we talked about building lower
end cheaper devices maybe the kind of
like
tiny device without a screen and then
again you run into the same car
insurance problem which is like that's
kind of boring
right like no one's going to get up here
and clap if we talk about the iphone 5s
or whatever it is you know not the s
what's the
no no no the se yeah yeah the sc it's
like oh and it's a little bit cheaper
and it comes in 10 fruity colors like
while i don't personally want to build
that i am
i would like to see those things exist
right i'm very much a believer in like
the big pie mentality of economics
so i would love to see people who are
capable of
you know building and managing like like
large numbers of devices that maybe
comma right now can't do
kind of getting in on the low end it's
gonna be hard for them to build a
high-end device
right because they don't have you know
the high-end devices work great because
they integrate really well with the
software you see this with android but
there's some people who just want any
kind of lcast system
and they'll buy up the low end right and
you see this exact same thing with
android the google pixel is a high-end
phone
the motorola j7 well it's 60 bucks and
it comes with a boost mobile you know
month
right um so like that's what i want to
see
from people in the common ecosystem but
hey if people want to compete on the
high end i love that too
right i just want to see all this stuff
get better because
self-driving cars are just the tip right
like self-driving cars are just the
beginning of
what all of this technology can allow i
want robots that clean my house and cook
me food
right it's the same tech we got a
question up there hello george good to
finally meet you in the flash
uh quick question can you uh touch on
what the microphones are for in the
comma three
i mean can i use it for nav or what are
they gonna do um
we put them in because it was easy uh
the comma two has a microphone as well
we're not recording you you guys can
read the code
um one of the first things that i'd like
to ship with the microphone
is something that adjusts the volume of
the alerts based on the ambient noise
level
right so we can use like a service to
estimate how many you know if you have
loud music playing the alert should be
louder
if you're in a dead silent car like a
hyundai sonata the alert should be
quieter if you're in a toyota corolla a
little louder right like
it should be it should so that's one of
the first uses of the microphone
uh the like voice nav stuff again the
oems kind of try this and while i think
we could build something better than the
oems there's still nothing that compares
to just
copying the address in your phone uh so
they're there because the hardware we're
just feeling complete without them
right on thank you got a question in the
front
yeah very excellent um i feel
embarrassed to say that i
own two teslas that i've already paid
for full self driving
well they're nice cars the software 14
000
spent on what i could have bought but uh
i saw in the thing on the website that
you're offering
this for the tesla will will it plug in
because i've been waiting for full
self-driving beta and i'm wondering if i
buy your device
and plug it in and it works maybe
they'll send me the full self-driving
beta
well um so so roma who was up here
earlier has a tesla
he's done a lot of the work pushing the
tesla port forward a bunch there's a
whole community of tesla people too
uh collude macgyver it's a lot
of community stuff so will it work yeah
you have to make one line change to the
code
the reason the tesla actually isn't
under community supported features is
we can't do the same kind of steering on
the tesla that we can on the other cars
it's very hard to make the tesla
steering wheel overrideable
it has that kind of tesla feel where
it's locked and then it disengages
we just don't think that's really an
open pilot experience but
it's relatively easy to do this we
should sell the tesla harness
um yeah we should uh
you can do it but it'll take a little
bit of work now it will get easier over
time
i remember that like also the stuff
that's live now is not i'm not selling
anybody full self driving i'm selling
this on the hardware specs
right like you're buying this for
hardware specs don't expect it tomorrow
to put this in your car and it's going
to make a 90-degree turn it's not
i'm not even that interested in that
what i am a lot more interested in with
this hardware and
the places where you're going to start
to see disparities between the two and
the three
are things like trucks in the
neighboring lane like moving over for
them right the comma two just can't see
them
another place you're gonna see a
disparity pretty soon if you don't
already
is detecting a far-off car at a
stoplight in a distance
right the comma two camera it's the lens
it just does not have that much
yeah um
as soon as you know we get as soon as we
sell like a thousand of these devices
and we start getting the data back from
them
uh we're gonna be able to train models
that significantly outperform the
comment too just because the raw data is
better
great i think that's uh that's it any
last questions
one more logan
could you speak a little bit more on the
dynamic range of these cameras and their
ability to see into like harsh lighting
conditions and things like that
uh it's a lot better than the comma 2
and tesla i'll say that um
they're ar 0231 you can look up the data
sheet of that sensor
uh multi-exposure 120 db i
think it's probably the highest dynamic
range camera you can reasonably buy
there are some in pre-production that
have a little bit more it's not
quite at the human eye level yet uh
but the human eye has absurd dynamic
range
um but it is the best thing on the
market today for that and it should be a
big step up from the comato
i think the human eye is like 150 this
is 120 the 2 was 85.
the tesla's 95.
i think that's it we did it
[Applause]
could be yours
you